hi good morning this is crazy
so my phone like I just woke up it is
let's see it's 651 I was up at like 4:30
with the dog and I went to plug my phone
and I was like I was a plug it in it's
at like 50% so whatever so I didn't plug
my phone in and I just woke up now again
at 6:51 and I go it does hurt my phone
on I don't I'm not even joking I can't
even touch this button it is it is
boiling hot I mean I could touch it but
it's it is like like it's burning my
finger and my phone will turn on what I
did do I think last night as I updated
to the latest OS but I'm pretty sure a
feature in that OS is uh not hey I'm
gonna I'm gonna boil your your finger
you can try to eat such ID or turn your
phone on it won't turn on it doesn't
smell like anything is burning except
the flush of my finger I guess I'll make
a Genius Bar appointment my phone back
why don't you do this to me didn't have
a plugged in did have it doing anything
I woke up with my phone next to me it
was boiling I like didn't even destroy
this phone yet like it just got it I
didn't even get Apple I think I got
apple pear no I don't know time to get
out of here what ok I guess my question
to you guys is is is your phone boiling
your finger still doesn't smell like
burning but there's definitely burning
should I try to like plug something into
it it's probably not a good idea but
it's not a bad idea
it's not a good idea I've had worse
ideas what do you think pop what do you
think he's wrong with my phone huh do
you think that maybe like your ears
match my phone you're a little toasted
marshmallow ears oh he's so cute
stop biting yourself babe you're eating
yourself alive and I don't know what to
do about it
what do I do help
okay so let's see what happens when I
plug something into it okay this is
still working my fingers it burns it's
burning his exercise a certain told her
the dilemma she's like did it happen
from charging I was like no my phone was
leaving plugged in oh it's turning on
but there was no way that my battery it
was dead because it was a 50% not too
long ago so definitely something is not
right
clearly yeah now it's a 36% and now the
button is not hot anymore this is weird
it's back to normal
oh thanks for my alarm to go off because
that wouldn't have woke up if the dog
didn't puke in my bed look if you need
an alarm just get a puppy he's lucky
that he's cute and I love him so much
he's real precious it looks like my
phone turned back on by plugging it in
it is no longer burning my finger man
that was crazy just a real wild Monday
morning so I'm gonna take him to the
Apple store and I'll see what they say
if they probably won't say anything and
they'll probably just say that's fine
and I will say can I get the rose gold
instead I think I might take a nap
until my Genius Bar appointment and
before I have to take my dog to the
dermatologist because he keeps biting
his flesh great day how's the you guys
later
hi so right now I've got everything sort
of organized by what I've been using
most I've got my calendar I've got my
clock